y
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo
ante la situación de kobe 19 ahora
trabajamos desde casa vuelve con fuerza
el llamado en redes sociales a boicotear
la nueva versión de moulin usuarios en
internet y activistas de derechos
humanos criticaron a disney por
presuntamente grabar parte de la
película en lugares de china donde
denuncian que se cometen violaciones a
los derechos humanos empezamos
la nueva versión de moulin finalmente
fue lanzada al mercado tras el retraso
provocado por el brote de kobe 19 en el
mundo la película se estrenó a través
del servicio de streaming de disney pero
hubo un detalle de la cinta que dio más
de que hablar que el propio contenido se
trata del lugar donde se habría
producido parte del rodaje la región
autónoma de xinjiang en china un
territorio de hermosos e impresionantes
paisajes que alberga la antigua ruta de
la seda y que ha estado bajo escrutinio
de la comunidad internacional por los
presuntos crímenes de lesa humanidad que
se cometen allí por parte del gobierno
chino la polémica estalló cuando los
espectadores se percataron de que en los
créditos de la cinta de disney incluyó
agradecimientos especiales a
instituciones gubernamentales de
yingjiang no hubo claridad inmediata
sobre cuál fue el trabajo que la
compañía realizó en ese lugar pero la
mención a estas entidades causó
indignación entre un sinnúmero de
internautas que bajo el numeral boicot
moulin llamaron a sabotear la cinta
entre los agradecimientos especiales se
encuentra la oficina de la policía de la
ciudad de tour funk en xinjiang esta
institución es señalada de administrar
campos de concentración donde se cree
que han sido detenidos más de un millón
de musulmanes que viven en esa región
principalmente miembros de la minoría
étnica uigur familiares de los detenidos
denuncian que en el interior de estos
lugares se cometen torturas trabajos
forzados desapariciones y hasta
esterilizaciones forzadas con el
objetivo de erradicar los china niega
tales acusaciones y describe estas
instalaciones como centros de
reeducación contra el extremismo
islámico el gobierno atribuye a
islamistas radicales los ataques
disturbios y enfrentamientos que se han
desatado en la región enmarcados en un
sentimiento separatista contra el
partido comunista que ha poblado la
región masivamente con miembros de la
etnia hand dominante en china con el
argumento de lucha contra el terrorismo
beijing intenta justificar la fuerte
presencia militar y extremas medidas de
represión desplegadas en la zona
el nuevo llamado a boicotear moulin
llega desde distintas partes del mundo
especialmente desde lugares donde
rechazan la injerencia de beijing desde
el exilio en australia el artista y
opositor al gobierno chino que se hace
llamar para wii chau acusó a disney de
apoyar el genocidio de los uigures y
publicó dos nuevas caricaturas en las
que recrea imágenes por las que beijing
ha sido objeto de críticas en una de
ellas se ve al personaje de moulin
custodiando a un gran grupo de uigures
en uno de los polémicos centros está
inspirada en la fotografía que vemos en
pantalla publicada en 2017 por la
justicia de xinjiang la otra es una
icónica imagen que tanto irrita a china
se trata del llamado rebelde desconocido
un hombre del tanque un sujeto que
intentó evitar que los tanques del
ejército chino reprimieran violentamente
las protestas de tiananmen en 1989 que
reclamaban democracia el resultado de
aquella jornada fueron cientos de
civiles muertos en el dibujo moulin es
representada como uno de los soldados
que maneja el tanque
esta no es la primera vez que surge el
llamado a boicotear anulan las críticas
contra la película iniciaron el año
pasado luego de que la protagonista li
fei manifestara su apoyo a la represión
contra las protestas en hong kong apoyo
a la policía de hong kong pueden
golpearme ahora dijo en mandarín a
través de la red social china weibo y
añadió en inglés que vergüenza para hong
kong
toni en otro de los actores de la
película celebró en facebook el
aniversario número 23 del fin de la
soberanía británica sobre hong kong
moulin la historia de la chica que se
convierte en una guerrera para defender
a su país se ha asociado con la
activista hong kong esa actriz show a
quienes los manifestantes llaman en
redes sociales la verdadera moulin en
respuesta a boicot moulin también ha
surgido la etiqueta support mullan por
parte de quienes defienden a la actriz y
a toda la producción
luego del primer boicot disney se limitó
a decir a la revista the hollywood
reporter que trataban de ser apolíticos
cuando se trata de estos temas y que
defendían la libertad de expresión
refiriéndose a los comentarios de la
actriz esta vez su directora financiera
solo dijo en una rueda de prensa que
están muy satisfechos con los resultados
de su apuesta virtual
hollywood cuenta con importantes
ingresos de china el segundo mercado
cinematográfico más grande del mundo los
medios de comunicación han insinuado que
con la nueva versión en la que
prescindieron del icónico dragón rojo
mucho que acompaña a moulin así como del
romance entre la guerrera y su capitán
disney está tratando de complacer a la
audiencia de este país de acuerdo con
the wall street journal después del
fracaso de la versión animada de moulin
de 1998 en la taquilla china disney hizo
varios esfuerzos citando a fuentes
conocedoras del tema dijo que para
evitar controversias y garantizar un
lanzamiento en ese país
la empresa compartió el guión con las
autoridades chinas mientras consultaba
con asesores locales la película costó
200 millones de dólares además del
estreno virtual en disney plans donde
acceder a ella tiene un costo de 30
dólares también se anunció su llegada a
los cines del gigante asiático de
acuerdo con la televisión central china
la decisión de la compañía puede
reflejar la creencia de que el mercado
chino podría hacer que el antídoto muy
necesario para restaurar la salud de una
taquilla enferma golpeada por el kobe 19
una columna del portal foro y policy
titula moulin tiene un mensaje sirva a
china y olvídense de los uigures en ella
dice que la película fue elaborada por
un equipo de guionistas occidentales que
parecen haber hecho muy poca tarea
hasta aquí revista digital recuerde que
si quiere repetir esta u otra emisión de
nuestro programa lo puede hacer a través
de nuestra página web www puntos 24
punto com
[Música]